you can either have multiple good days
in a row or you can be an entrepreneur
but you can't have both there's a
limiting belief of some kind there's
someone who has told a story that you've
decided to believe
and if you can surround yourself by
people who have found a way
to create empowering beliefs out of
those same things that you might
currently believe are limitations
you get now the permission to be
courageous in spaces you haven't been in
before mastery is a thing that you can
develop or that expertise is a thing
that you can develop but appreciate
that that kind of expertise happens over
time who did i want to be
before i became who i'd become
oh
dave hollis in the house what is
happening kevin carmichael
i love him man where are you uh i am in
the backyard of heidi's house here in
arizona
it's uh two nights a day to not uh sit
out here and enjoy a little sun while
i'm hanging out with my buddy i'm very
jealous it's getting certain to get cold
here in canada certainly really yeah
yeah winter jacket time so i'm jealous
arizona dude it was a little chilly this
morning but it's like
723 degrees out here right now it's
perfect
i'm sorry i'm not trying to rub it in
yeah thank you thank you for that thank
you my friend okay listen guys we're
talking to dave hollis author of the new
book built through courage for youtube
check the description below to get your
copy of the book dude i'm so excited for
this book um your first book was awesome
thank you who's that guy don't even
recognize him this yeah wow with all
shade look at this baby up here look
what a baby face huh
so listen i
i uh this took me like six months to
read
mostly because i'm a slow reader it was
a great book i'm just a slow reader you
wanna save like five things at a time or
ten things at a time you you go through
a bunch of different books each week
well i see i like i like to micro dose
on books
you know it's like i get a little bit of
dave every ten day every week the ten
days like oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
and what i what i realized was how much
i missed
the vibe because i was micro dosing on
dave hollis content through this book
for like six months and this is not that
thick a book right six months and then
and then i had nothing for a while and
then this book came along like oh yeah
that's what i'm missing
here we go
and in reading it the first thought that
came to my mind besides the warm feeling
like ah i miss this guy is your books
are like
it's like i'm eating candy
but but there's like a stake in the
middle
you know and that like it's so easy to
to it's so easy to put in your mouth
it's so easy to pick up and read it
feels like it's so friendly and fun and
authentic and true
but it's also a meal it feels like a
meal like i'm i'm reading it it's so
easy to go through but then at the end
of a chapter it's like i gotta digest
this what did i just go through right i
don't know that makes but that's the
first thought that came to my mind it's
like this super delicious candy but in
the middle is a steak and you feel full
at the end of it man i love that that's
an awesome compliment thanks brother
that's really great i mean like the hope
is
you can tell stories as an author that
people can see
uh themselves in
but that also after you
have them see themselves that maybe you
can also
challenge them to
do a little bit of active learning with
a prompt a journaling prompt of some
kind something that might have them take
an observation that i had because my
observations aren't necessarily going to
be the ones that you
also have as the reader the hope is that
you can come to your own conclusions
that you have your own breakthroughs
that something that is said
has you created something of empathy
between my story and yours but that also
the thing that you might need as a
result of having that breakthrough might
be different and so i mean i just i love
any book that asks me to think
or sends me into a journaling prompt
kind of experience and so i tried to
bring that into this and uh the
feedback's been great so far so i'm
encouraged to hear what you think of the
of the journaling prompts and the way
that active learning pairs with passive
listening or passive reading as well
yeah so i'm i'm
i'm i have two reading sessions in so i
like again i'll microdose some of this
because i need my little bit of devalus
as we go through what i'm what i'm
curious about is called built built
through courage dave hollis go check it
out youtube description go go pick up
your copy i got mine i got the signed
copy because i know this man
where is it where is it
it says it says let's go
they apologize actually i almost didn't
get a copy of this i had to like hound
you you didn't leave one on my table i
don't know i mean
that was a mistake i don't know how that
could have possibly been i had to hound
this guy to get me a copy of the book
early and sign it so anyway i'm excited
um so courage listen how do we take
how do we take we all know we need
courage my artist is entrepreneurs to
start a business it takes crazy amounts
of courage and you've gone through that
of leaving disney and then business and
a new business
how do we turn courage into
from subconscious to conscious right
like i think we just play small by
default
i think
uh probably like 10 times today i've
already played small and not done the
thing that i should have done if it just
came to the conscious mind so how do you
turn that into a muscle that it becomes
conscious how do we recognize when we're
playing small
well i mean i think first you have to
find a way to surround yourself with
people that will normalize their
experience and walking into things that
you're currently avoiding like if
there's something that because of your
fear
something because of
the way that insecurity or the voices or
you know could be your own voice could
be the voices of someone else
could be that there's a limiting belief
that exists i mean dogs all right yep
and i'm moving i'm moving locations
because dogs bear with me people
it adds to the ambiance i mean i didn't
think dogs were going to be the problem
that we had this morning uh
but like there's a there's a limiting
belief of some kind there's someone who
has told a story that you've decided to
believe
and if you can surround yourself by
people who have found a way
to
create empowering beliefs out of those
same things that you might currently
believe are limitations you get now the
permission to be courageous in spaces
you haven't been in before
so i mean i tell the story in the book
of my transition from disney into
entrepreneurship i went from this place
where
there was a team of people that
absolutely had a nose for smoke like i
had this like super deep team of experts
they had just expertise forever and ever
and the thing that their expertise
brought them was that they could sniff
out fire before
it came and became fire and most often
as a leader i was getting updates of
things that they
had identified as potential problems and
extinguished before they became bigger
problems
when i got into entrepreneurship i was
with now a team of people that so many
of us had never even been in the space
that we were now walking in
that we didn't have a nose for smoke
because we'd never even smelled fire
before
and now the frequency of fire that we
were experiencing and having to
extinguish was happening at such a fast
pace
that it challenged the way that i
thought about me being the right kind of
leader for the space where
i was relatively free from fire because
of the way that my team was handling it
in corporate and now was always just in
fire doing so much work to try and
change you know the problem we were
having or reframe the failure we were
going through but it got to me and it
messed with my
with my belief in self it was uh it was
an imposter syndrome kind of thing
and i had this opportunity about six
months in
where my ex-wife was speaking at an
event with john maxwell great leadership
dude and john maxwell and i was
sharing this like man i don't understand
i don't know how to handle the
self-doubt that's now been created of me
inside of this entrepreneurial space
where i can't preempt fires from
happening
and he just said something so simple and
it was hey you can either have multiple
good days in a row or you can be an
entrepreneur but you can't have both
right like you can run a small business
or you can have multiple good days in a
row and what was beautiful is like being
able to have
this person who has so much experience
in leadership and had so much experience
in the kind of thing that i was
experiencing failing normalized that it
was just the price of entry for anyone
who is in a small business or wants to
grow a small business to have to deal
with fire
that it made me number one afford myself
just a wild amount of grace oh be
graceful you're gonna of course make
mistakes because that's part of
what happens when you're running the
small business but also
in that posture i was able to think
differently about how this failure every
time or these fires every time
were the reasons why we now had a better
understanding of the systems or the
process or the people or the product or
whatever it was that was necessary to
not have us have the same kind of fire
again we learned and grew because of not
in spite of those fires coming up in the
first place
i love that story it's in the voice in
the first part of the books i've already
gone through that like oh that's a good
i think i underlined that quote it's a
good one john maxwell um
a lot of entrepreneurs
are probably the most courageous people
in their circles
you know like they are the most they are
the ones porn and others they are the
ones trying to choose after their dreams
but then also encourage others to go
after their dreams because they don't
have a giant support system and it's
great to pour in others but how do you
how do you start to surround yourself
with those people who then
push you to be more courageous if we
can't all hang out with john maxwell
well i mean i think it has to become
part of the culture that you create
inside of the space that you're
operating like you have to have a
we will continue to take chances and
failure isn't going to be something we
wear as an indictment of us not being
smart or good or having thought about it
well enough but as the thing that was
necessary for us to in making that
mistake understand where we have
opportunities to grow or rewarding
people for responsible risk or
challenging people to be innovators in a
way that doesn't have the likelihood of
their innovation not being perfect at
first a thing that you are going to take
time and actually have some reward and
recognition kind of conversation around
on a monthly basis or whatever it might
be you want to encourage people to put
themselves out there and take some risks
because it's in the risk that you're
going to have most of the breakthroughs
that'll take your business to or your
your product to a place that you'd hope
for it to go if you stay inside of
something that is familiar or that is
routine or that is status quo as
competition acts as a little bit more as
i call it the insurgent versus the
incumbent mentality um if you if you are
operating as more of an incumbent trust
me the insurgents will take you out and
in the book i have a chapter that talks
a little bit about
this thing that i've talked to my teams
about over the course of time every time
i had a chance and that was
if you want to innovate if you want to
grow if you want to keep up with
technology and trends and you know
frankly everything and anything that's
happening in the world around you that
your customers
are of course
considerate of because they are also
living in the real world then you have
to embrace something of an insurgent's
mentality that person that like never
takes their market position for granted
that never thinks the things that are
will be that always is scanning the
horizon for what ends up being next and
is willing to invest short-term capital
into long-term opportunity and the
example i use in the book of course
everyone knows it is this difference
between blockbuster and netflix where at
the time that i was still working at
disney blockbuster was the preeminent
the the number one in you know home
entertainment they were a staple in what
you did on friday nights
and at the time that i was there netflix
actually approached them about allowing
that allowing blockbuster to buy them
for 50 million dollars which was like
overstating the market cap of that small
company at the time they had a belief in
where they were going and of course
blockbuster said no they stuck to the
status quo people are always going to go
to this blue building on friday nights
and rent packaged goods and netflix the
insurgent was like no we're going to
invest in technology we're going to
create a business model that tries to as
a like a wayne gretzky kind of way shoot
you know pass the puck to where the
skater is going instead of where the
skater is and so i think there was
something in their willingness to
invest in the future and think about
disruption and leverage technology and
understand consumer demand is a thing
that shifts
that had them doing things that a more
complacent insert like a
incumbent in blockbuster just didn't do
and of course what happened right
blockbuster is now gone i think there's
one store that's left
netflix is a you know
multiple billions of dollars market cap
company and has a huge huge business
sitting in front of them because they
not only were they in insurgent but
continue to be one and how they approach
now production and how they produce you
know approach all of the things that
they're doing and moving talent deals
here and creating like high high quality
content that competes certainly with day
and date films in theaters so you know
be the insurgent is the big message
so you go from
fast track to success in the corporate
world of disney you know to business
number one to then business number two
between business one and two
was there a thought at all of maybe i
should go back to corporate
it's interesting i
i guess there was but um i i really
was in moving out of corporate
attempting to follow calling at the
expense of certainty the pla the pieces
of me that were considering going back
to corporate and thinking about whether
or not i ought to return to
wearing pants and having a tie
or are you are you wearing pants dave i
hope you're wearing some paint wearing
shorts now thank you very much okay
there we go pants that cover knees right
like i've got a job now where i don't
have to wear pants to cover my knees on
a very regular basis and there's
something great about that but um when i
the the thing the voice that was drawing
me to consider the possibility of going
back into that space was fear was my
previous relationship with certainty was
the way that
i knew i could have you know something
that was a little more guaranteed
relative to what in this now line of
work is more of a betting on yourself
believing in yourself tapping into what
you believe to be your gifts and having
a little bit of faith that yep you were
put here for this reason that in that
reason you are now going to lean into it
and attempt to
activate your potential to get closer to
delivering on your purpose
and i actually have this really
beautiful experience in
having been asked if i would be an
expert witness tell the story in the
book to ask if i'd be an expert witness
for an entertainment case that like
specifically my 20 years in the job and
specifically my last
seven as that theatrical film had
made me a good candidate for
and so i read through all the
depositions and i was prepared for the
cross-examination and i did a bunch of
reports myself and then found myself on
the stand
and it was this fantastic thing that
happened to happen i don't think that's
coincidence because it was delayed a
couple of times just as i am once again
faced with identity shift
in the midst of now not going to be
working with rachel any longer having to
figure out what's next and i got in that
courtroom via zoom i was wearing a suit
with flip-flops
i got into that courtroom
and i was at my very best because i did
over 20 years with the time create
expertise inside of this piece of
entertainment that had me connecting to
mastery that had me connecting to some
of the most confident pieces of myself
because of that two decades worth of
time that i'd spent in that world
and what it reminded me is that yeah i
had created expertise i had done enough
work and spent enough time developing
skills that became something in the
world of mastery to make me the expert
that i was
and that because i did it before it was
this reminder that i could do it again
it was also a reminder that my expertise
is something that was built over 20
years worth of time as in it is going to
take time
and so the gift was that reminder that
hey
you
need not rush because of fear back to
something safe at the expense of who
you're placed here to be
you need to be patient
you need to be patient with this
reminder that mastery is a thing that
you can develop or that expertise is a
thing that you can develop but
appreciate that that kind of expertise
happens over time
you know like i'm i am an author i
consider myself an author i'm like two
years into being an author
so like 10 times the amount of time from
now i hope that i have the kind of
expertise as an author that i took and
spent 20 years in building in the
entertainment career so that it's just
it feels different because of course
i am so proud of this book it's one of
the greatest things i've ever created in
my entire life
and i am super hopeful that the next 18
years on top of the two that i've
already spent as a writer are just going
to make me a better writer that yeah i
love to speak
and i think i'm pretty good at
delivering a message on a stage and yet
i'm just starting like i'm not as good
as i will be because it takes time to
develop mastery and so for anyone who's
listening if you feel yourself connected
to passion or purpose you feel like you
are in
calling but it is frustrating because
it's a little uncertain or it's
something that hasn't delivered the
return that you're hoping for yet
part of what you probably need most is
time to just continue to toil a little
bit in getting it as good as you can but
not perfect because you are just in real
time developing mastery of course it's
not going to be as good as it will be
over time because it just takes time to
get better
so in that transition like company one
you could have gone the scared way and
gone back to corporate you could have
done the courage way and gone back and
started a new business which you did
going back to that dave which which
chapter in this book did that dave need
the most
well i mean i tell the story uh of
meeting dan rather
and it's an important story because it
asks a big question that if you are
someone who finds themselves stuck finds
themselves wondering
who the heck am i supposed to be if i'm
not who i've been i'm feeling frustrated
that there's a disconnection between
what i do and how it feels like it
honors the purpose that i'm here for
i i talk a lot about
i believe that each of us was made with
very specific design in mind you evan me
we've each had unique experiences we
have unique wiring we have unique skills
and all of that was a part of a
deliberateness that happened at creation
and i believe that part of what we're
here to do is honor
the intention of our creator
and here i had been doing something in
corporate for so long that i am proud of
and yet
i was climbing a ladder for 20 years
thinking i might finally get to a rung
where it felt like it was going to give
me those things i had been sold or that
i was hoping for until i realized
realized 20 years in i was climbing the
wrong ladder
and now that i find myself in the space
that i do i do feel like i'm climbing
the right ladder it's just gonna of
course take time to develop the mastery
over time
but to identify the right ladder i had
to ask this question to bring it back to
dan rather
who did i want to be
before i became who i'd become
who did i want to be at the beginning
because i think so much of who we want
to be at the beginning is connected
to
that part of our life where we are still
attuned to and haven't let the the world
talk us out of believing our intuition
that gut as glenn doyle might call it
our knowing voice of god whatever you
want to call it but there is a voice
that lives inside of us
that we believe until we're convinced to
not believe it and so going back to who
i wanted to be
before i became who i'd become was this
important question and as i was
wrestling with it i was trying so badly
to
um
figure out the answer and then i was sat
on a plane next to dan rather and as i
said on this plane next to dan rather i
get like generosity of this person who
happens to have also been as a sign of
how nerdy i was growing up my childhood
hero like i just wanted to be dan rather
when i was growing up i had a an
anchor's job as a college student where
i was doing the local news with huge
shoulder pads in an oversized suit i was
doing like just everything i could to
become a reporter djing at 2am and then
i got into the corporate track and i
slowly
abandoned made peace with not being that
thing that i dreamed of forever and i
got off the plane after what was like a
two-hour conversation and i was like
goodness gracious i
wanted to be a reporter before i became
who i did as an executive or who i
became as i did and someone supporting a
business i was running with rachel and i
realized as much as it's hard for me to
explain to my 99 year old grandma who is
asking always dave do you have a career
should we be worried about you
um
that the easiest way for me to explain
what i do as an author
what i do as a coach what i do is
someone who hosts a podcast
that that those things are reporting
thankfully not the news but like i am
reporting the stories of my own
experiences and the way that i in
interacting with people i respect like
you and so many of our friends that i
might be able to bring together some of
that storytelling in a way that it can
be received to afford someone a
breakthrough and how they also might
reach for a better
part of their life better kind of
attempt at getting to purpose and so
you know i'm a reporter and now that i
know it i can't unknow it right like i'm
climbing the ladder of being a reporter
in an unconventional way but in a way
that has me so connected to this being
the passion of my life and the purpose
of my life that was designed wildly
longer ahead of me even having a
conscious knowing of it
i love it man that's a great story i'm
looking forward to getting to that part
in the book um
somebody asked me this morning
how to figure out their 10-year goals
for themselves
and uh i'd be curious your perspective
because for me it's like how do you if
you have 10-year plans for yourself
you're thinking small like you have no
idea what you're capable of in the
10-year window and just looking at where
you've been you know in the last four
years let alone 10 years
i get this like there's this desire to
have some kind of clarity and certainty
over your life's plan but then you need
to have the courage to say i like how
you said it like switch the ladder like
oh my gosh this actually isn't the
ladder for me to go jump here
what would you tell somebody who's
struggling to figure out their 10-year
plan
i i mean i couldn't agree with you more
and i used to be someone that would cast
this vision of who i wanted to be five
ten years seems crazy five years at
least in the future
and i have always because i think it's
just a part of our humanity undersold
the possibilities of how much we could
grow and change
in a five-year window of time that there
was never an ability to actually really
connect to something that was as
audacious as i think we are capable as
humans so i
uh i actually just i try to think of um
moments which this is maybe a little bit
crazy but like i think of like a big
milestone birthday party in the future
right i'm 46 so call it 60 right in 15
years if i had people come together for
a birthday party
what are the things i'd hoped that they
might toast about the way i've had an
impact on them as individuals and the
world that they live in or i mean this
is a little morbid but i'm going to die
one day so are you i hate to break it to
you tre spoiler alert but
at my
funeral
like i've had the consideration of what
kind of video i want to play
at that ceremony where people
are celebrating the way that i lived my
life
so i can connect to like generally
speaking the things i hope that people
might say
and when i think about that now i'm able
to okay how would i have to act
every single day to engineer the
possibility
of actually
giving those toasts or that eulogy or
that video a chance to happen without
getting so specific i i set short-term
goals but
i will say like when i was at the
beginning of
hard season like 2020 was a very very
hard year i know it's hard for everybody
um i had a hard time thinking about a
year in the future
and so the thing that allowed me to
create some inertia some momentum was
just wildly reducing
the time horizon that i was considering
and i started asking like what do i need
today knowing the situation i find
myself in
to just get 90 days in the future
so that i'm like continuing to make some
progress it's not going to be totally
linear it's like a non-linear kind of
thing but hopefully bottom left of chart
to top right of chart is the direction
that it's heading over time
but
i try to take it in smaller chunks so
that the way that you potentially in
going to smaller chunks gives you the
chance to just
take micro goals or little smaller doses
of what it is that you're going to need
in the short term to get to where you
want to go in the long term so i don't
know i don't know that it's possible for
you to necessarily
cast a 10-year vision because of the way
that we underestimate the ability that
we have to
do wildly more than we think we can
so if we cast our our life forward and i
know we're kind of hitting the clock so
we can own this because i'm super
excited
you cast the clock forward to age 60 or
to your your death and hopefully there's
a long time between those two uh moments
in time
what is the message that you hope rings
through from the people who you've had
an impact on what do you want them
saying
i mean as i think about my four kids who
at 60 will be
adults human children you know i hope
that they are able to say
this is a guy as my father that modeled
the importance of believing in himself
and pushing himself outside of spaces
that were safe and otherwise would have
kept him stuck
to follow what he believed to be his
calling in life he did it in a way that
was consistently showing us that courage
was required that you have to believe as
my little tattoo here says right the the
tattoo is all about this belief that you
were built for the choppy waters that
ultimately afford you this opportunity
for the kind of growth that you need
and i i just hope that there's they will
recognize that hey he was someone who
was modeling that for us and that in
doing so
was able
to honor the intention of a creator
that put him here
with light to give light to as many
people as possible
and that i did it even though i was
going to make mistakes i did it even
though i was going to get some things
wrong and fail and learn from those
failures i'd be embarrassed here and
there i did it even though i was gonna
have to challenge most of the fears that
i've had for my entire life
because fear of course is something that
is on all sides of your comfort zone and
that the only way you're gonna get to
impact or purpose or finding your way
through to learning and growth where
fulfillment might exist is by becoming
courageous and facing that fear i hope
they say that i got courageous and faced
my fear to do the things that i was
placed on this planet to do
and just a quick follow-up if you had to
think of america so those are your kids
but like imagine dave the author
somebody has read these two books and
the next like 80 books that you're going
to produce over your your lifetime
they've read every book you've done
but they've never written to you they
never left a comment they never sent
anything of love but they're going to
show up to your funeral and say
something
what do you hope that they say
i hope that they say that in some way
the belief that they have in themselves
was something that they were able to
model for their kids that the way that
they were able to tap into courage gave
them proximity to purpose in a way that
gave permission for their people and
their people's people to have that same
courage as a part of their story as well
that
facing your fear or challenging your
limiting beliefs became something
because of having been inspired by
something they read or being influenced
by something you saw or being in
community with other people that
like-mindedly decided you know what
we're going to be scared but we're going
to do it scared anyway let's get
courageous and go and to me like that
there's no greater honor tribute than
just having someone
decide that they're going to take on the
mantle of courage so they might also
unleash their gifts to the world in a
way that tells the rest of the people
around them that they also have that
same
obligation maybe is the wrong word but
opportunity at a minimum right they have
that same opportunity and that even
though it might be scary it is something
that they can do and when they decide to
they're going to feel so good about
themselves when they're by themselves
that it'll be worth it
dave hollis ladies and gentlemen let's
go evan carmichael come on
it's built built through courage it
tastes like candy but you're getting a
nutritious meal all the way through go
check it out youtube the link is in the
description below appreciate you so much
man thank you for doing this and i
appreciate you brother you've been so
supportive i just i cannot say enough i
thank you for today but also for all the
support you've been given over these
years man i appreciate you
much love thank you man all right see
you soon
sounds good
if you want to see my last one-on-one
with dave hollis check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there my strategy in the short term
is focus on the things that will move
the needle most
first in real time i'm focusing on like
in the next 30 to 90 days how can i best
honor the intention of my creator